لا يمكننا المخاطره بمستقبل معاشاتنا
التقاعديه ان هذا الاصلاح ضروري ولانني
متمسكه بنموذجنا الاجتماعي ولانني اؤمن
بالديمقراطيه البرلمانيه فان الاصلاح بنص
البرلمان ثمره حل وسط بين المجلسين وانا
مستعده لتحمل المسؤوليه
قانون سن التقاعد في فرنسا
مررت الحكومه الفرنسيه القانون دون تصويت
مجلس النواب اعتمادا على الماده 49.3
القرار الذي طرحه الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
لرفع سن التقاعد من 62 الى 64 عاما
ينص على ضمان تمويل نظام الضمان الاجتماعي
الذي يشكل احد ركائز النموذج الفرنسي
ينص على زياده مده الاشتراكات المطلوبه في
الضمان الاجتماعي من 42 عاما الى 43 عاما
لكي يحصل المتقاعد على معاشه التقاعدي
كاملا اي من دون ان تلحق به اي خصومات
سن التقاعد في فرنسا هو الادنى بين الدول
الاوروبيه
وكان مشروع القانون دافعا لملايين
الفرنسيين للتظاهر رفضا للقرار